you've said that you never felt like you
fit in
growing up you moved around a lot yeah
what was it that specifically that made
you feel like you didn't fit in
well first of all i was born in l.a then
my dad was like
this family doesn't have enough
discipline and moved us to senegal west
africa where he's from
wait a minute when my dad said we don't
have enough discipline we lost
television rights
for three hours no one took us to africa
flew us to another continent and then we
moved to
maryland potomac maryland and then back
to la but i was switching schools every
two years it was just
a lot so did you do you visit senegal a
lot since then have you gone back since
you lived in senegal i have a visited i
used to visit my cousins a lot when i
was younger and
it's funny because they like they like
my americanness made me it was like a
currency it gave me street credit
like um because they were there weren't
a lot of shows that they were watching
but they were watching like baywatch
and 90210 like every day at 4 o'clock
and 4 30. those were the two those shows
were
all over the world but late like six
months later in senegal so they were
watching things and i didn't watch those
shows
but they would always say like oh my
gosh you live in l.a you live in beverly
hills like
do you know do you know like kelly and
dylan and i'd be like
yeah i know them
the other day and they really and they
bought it meanwhile
like i'd go you know be african in in
america with my american friends
and they would be like uh do you have a
lion in your backyard
that was my next question i mean thanks
yeah that's
yeah now you went to a mostly white
school predominantly white school
in maryland so that's got to be an odd
experience
yeah i mean i was young so i didn't
really think much
of it it was just like i would always
get the questions for like black culture
they'd be like oh
like what's this dance craze can you do
it and then you know i'm not a great
dancer i can't i can't dance
at all but um i would always give it a
shot and then they they knew
like they shouldn't ask me anymore so
that was
i did it's to be irritating you must
know the dance pranks do it perform it
and
i ca i can't it's just hard to learn
dances but i mean i was i was
pretty much just like the token black
girl at the end of the day
right right and so they would expect you
to watch certain shows
like i even at work you know when i was
when i had a job before this
it was just about like the atlanta
housewives or something i do watch
reality shows but atlanta housewives is
actually not trashy enough for me so i
don't watch it
but they'll ask what's the trashiest one
that you watch uh loving hip-hop but
then it
it it got like untrashy because it's
more scripted i just don't
you know i wanted to i want to know what
i'm watching is like
real pure trash yeah that's not
that's not that you're at the right
place
[Applause]
congratulations